the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones
hey guys filming for season seven has
already wrapped up and while we also did
we won't see any seasons and spoiler
related material until the official
trailer for season seven comes out we
were wrong yesterday were leaked nine
photos from filming set which are of
course not taken yesterday but we're
taking probably months ago but for
yesterday League for a first time beside
those nine more than interestingly
photos that I'm going to show and
explain to you in the same video I'm
also bringing an official teaser for
Game of Thrones Season seven that HBO
released yesterday let's start with
those leaked photos in the first one we
can see a stark bedroom which is
probably taken at their Winterfell set
at money glass well this first one is
not particularly exciting League which
every next photo the excitement grows
more and more next league photo is only
confirming once again that we are going
to see Casterly Rock
the obsessor stronghold of House
Lannister in the upcoming season which
Gold Alliance above the archway with the
red lettering in the centre are
confirming let me remind you that we
have already knew that we are going to
see Casterly Rock in season 7 as a few
months ago is so a few leaked photos of
true Co Castle along with a few leaks
scenes that included Jaime and Bronn a
few scenes that will take place in or
dimensioned
Lannister stronghold in the following
filing photos you can see the unsullied
elite soldiers standing beside a large
construction forming up in front of a
ship said that should represent urines
personal ship the silence that is said
to be infamous from eben to shy on that
same set we can see the on solid helmets
shields and spears which are their basic
tools that they are using for their
battle tactics that are based on the
legions of the old great empires with
large group of them fighting in lockstep
palanca is using spear and shield which
along with their gyro discipline makes
them one of the greatest arming game
experience world resulting with their
not breaking even the face of
overwhelming gods this idea of solid we
can also see Lancer soldiers that
apparently were on the same set with
already mentioned elite warrior units
well I've seen a lot of fan speculations
about those two armies being together
which of your fans thinks will represent
a flee battle between urine and danerys
since urine ship was all from that same
sad my opinion is that those scenes from
the same set will take place in the
final episodes of the upcoming season
definitely want to represent a flee
battle that is going to take place in
the first episode of season 7 the same
flee battle that will result with the
death of one and the capture of father
sense things that's righteously battle
along with your Greyjoy I came to this
conclusion upon reminding the first
leaked photos in which we could clearly
see Daenerys along with her two armies
planning a Dragonstone which means that
in the first flip battle only rnt on
supported by then is Li by the sand
snakes will attack your own starfleet
vials on the other hand during this same
plea battle Lannisters and urine one be
allies but will be come upon this year's
victory as you could see him coming to
King's Landing upon his glorious victory
and pledging his forces to Cersei those
tags that I mentioned a few moments ago
our own confirming that those leaked
photos of your ship of the unsullied and
of the Lancer soldiers will take place
in the final episodes of the upcoming
season in the last bully photos that
we're taking at Walsall query we can see
a white and a group of Wildings standing
beneath a cliff face those two photos
our own confirming already confirmed
theory a theory in which chunks now
release small force beyond the wall on a
mission to catch a white in order to
prove the rest Westeros the real war is
coming which will result with night
Kings ambush in which Johnson will
almost die theory that has been refused
by so many fans but at the time was
passing more and more proofs for going
in favor to this theory which resulted
with this theory becoming confirmed
event of season 7 if you're not
introduced with this event that will
take place in season 7 feel free to
check it out those 9 leaked photos are
only confirming the already existing and
proven theories but it's always nice and
exciting to see any leaked related to
Game of Thrones series now let's focus
on a new official teaser for season 7
that HP released yesterday it's
something spectacular it's a short clip
that doesn't even include any actor but
it's all for the first official teaser
after a long time yesterday
during one of its promotional segments a
brief HBO in production clip of volt
keeper aired it's a short seven second
video for hand-holding old skipper
Valyrian steel sword as Jamie gave to
Brienne as a gift in order to defend and
keep sense of stark safe at first it
seems like a normal not suspicious video
but upon watching it we can notice that
the hand that is holding all steeper
doesn't look like Brienne's which could
mean that Brienne won't survive the
upcoming season let me know your
thoughts on those night league photos
and on this short teaser for season 7 in
the comment section down below hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace
[Music]
you